[Musique]
kim
tha
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
médiocre lâche paul est un scientifique
mal dans sa peau son travail va changer
sa vie après un incident dans son
laboratoire il se voit doté de super
pouvoirs
[Musique]
des pouvoirs qui vont devenir de plus en
plus dévorant dans ses pièces frédéric
sonntag revisite le mythe de l'antihéros
cette course au succès que la société
nous impose et variées des personnages
qui sont un type à côté qui arrive pas
et j'aimais bien l'idée de raconter
aussi l'histoire de ce qui tombe de ceux
qui trébuche de ceux qui qui sont pas
qu'ils arrivent pas complètement rentrer
dans le costume et il faut faire le
récit de ces gens là aussi tu nombreux
pâtissiers
du rire de tout
[Applaudissements]
un
spectacle joué pour la première fois
sous forme de diptyque beautiful loser
ces composés de l'icann man et de
l'histoire de the shaggs considéré comme
le plus mauvais groupes de rock de tous
les temps les deux destins se répondent
et se rejoignent frédéric sonntag joue
avec les codes des comics et du biopic
seconde mythologie qui appelle
l'utilisation de l'image d'utilisation
de la musique donc il ya de la musique
en direct sur scène qui est jouée par
deux musiciens iliad et beaucoup de
vidéos aussi beaucoup de l'image on
utilise beaucoup l'image pour pouvoir
raconter ce qui est à la fois d'un côté
le principe du biopic c'est à dire
l'histoire d'un groupe de rock et
comment ce groupe va naître et va
évoluer avec un peu tous les motifs
habituel du super héros et en même temps
de l'autre côté tous les motifs habituel
aussi de l'histoire d'un groupe de rock
doit reprendre tous ces motifs la pour
les analyser les regarder voire un peu
aussi l'affluence de ces figures là sur
notre imaginaire des figures sublimer
dans l'échec des perdants réunis sous
une même réflexion sur la popularité et
le prix à payer pour l'atteindre
[Musique]